it just exploded Nationwide it was a  cultural phenomenon what color is  happier than purple  this is what he sounded like Barney  stands for inclusion acceptance you  should love everyone we all have Cheryl  leech to thank for that as her beloved  character was heading into the  stratosphere people couldn't accept that  this was just a show and so let the  bashing begin  some of the rumors that I heard Barney  Heights drugs in his tail they were  violent and explicit death and  dismemberment of my family I love you  Barbie they were going to come and find  me and they were going to kill me just  the dark side of this whole moment that  must have devastated Cheryl there was  something larger going on here  I don't think you could ever think  somebody would go and shoot someone  [Music]